[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo soy
un líder riaño y hoy los saludo desde
casa
[Música]
aunque el kobe 19 paralizó por unos
meses las actividades en el mundo no lo
hizo con la violencia la pobreza y los
conflictos que obligan a miles de
personas a huir por eso el éxodo volvió
a ser noticia tras el relajamiento de
medidas tomadas contra la pandemia pese
a que el virus aún sigue activo en
centroamérica avanza una nueva caravana
de migrantes que buscan el sueño
americano a kilómetros en bosnia
herzegovina otros tantos quieren llegar
a los países de la unión europea a
través de la ruta de los balcanes por
eso hoy los invito a conocer lo que pasa
con los que huyen en estos lugares
empezamos en centroamérica donde más de
3000 personas se movilizan en un grupo
en la primera caravana que se forma en
tiempos de pandemia
nuevamente san pedro sula fue la ciudad
de partida de una caravana de migrantes
hondureños
sin trabajo azotados por la violencia y
en crisis por el coronavirus decidieron
emprender la marcha aprovechando la
apertura de las fronteras entre los
países centroamericanos tras seis meses
de cierre los hondureños dicen no
aguantar más ya que el gobierno no sirve
y no lo ha aportado nada no que dejen
aprenderme a muchos hemos perdido el
trabajo ya que ante aumento es por donde
vamos para adelante porque no tenemos
trabajo no tenemos nada que hacer solo
un día les como llegar hasta el punto
fronterizo de el corinto en la zona
limítrofe con guatemala un buen grupo de
hondureños no atendió los controles de
entrada y cruzó a la fuerza tras romper
el cerco de las autoridades
guatemaltecas e informaron que al menos
tres mil llegaron a su territorio
ante el paso de los migrantes que
cruzaron sin cumplir con los requisitos
de seguridad por el coni 19 el gobierno
de guatemala tomó medidas
les pedimos a todos los que entraron
ilegalmente que por favor procedan a
regresar porque en este momento se ha
dado la orden de que sean detenidos en
territorio guatemalteco a todos aquellos
que han entrado ilegalmente y se han
retornado a la frontera de su país una
decisión que se aplicó rápidamente para
evitar el avance de los hondureños y que
llevó a algunos a desistir de la marcha
y si tomamos la decisión de bote de
regresarlos por qué
la situación estaba un poco bien
complicada el presidente de guatemala
tomó decisiones en
medidas drásticas en cerrar 15 días y un
inmigrante no tiene la capacidad para
aguantar todo ese tiempo sin comer
los centroamericanos que lograron evadir
los controles de las autoridades en
guatemala continuarán su periplo hacia
eeuu pero a los centroamericanos aún les
restan miles de kilómetros antes de
llegar a destino y deben cruzar méxico
un paso difícil ante el despliegue de
efectivos de la guardia nacional en las
fronteras para contener el tránsito de
los migrantes ahora revisemos lo que
pasa en otra frontera la ruta de los
balcanes es el trayecto usado por los
migrantes para continuar su recorrido
hacia los países de la unión europea y
es tomada por muchos ya que es
considerada menos peligrosa que el viaje
por el mar mediterráneo sin embargo
cientos quedan varados en
bosnia-herzegovina antes de poder llegar
a destino la mayoría de los migrantes se
concentran en las regiones de frontera
con croacia
atrapados en voz mujer segundo esa es la
situación de cientos de migrantes y
solicitantes de asilo que quedaron a la
deriva tras el cierre de centros de
acogida en el país
los menores fueron trasladados a un
campo de recepción pero al menos 400
adultos no tienen refugio y se enfrentan
a los riesgos de la pandemia y a las
bajas temperaturas del invierno algunos
optaron por quedarse en el bosque pero
las necesidades abundan
y la gente no tiene comida compruébalo
con ellos van conmigo en dos o tres días
tenemos demasiados problemas de thriller
no sólo zumos porque anhelan cruzar a
croacia para continuar su viaje por
europa algunos ya lo han intentado
varias veces pero no lo han logrado
me dijeron ve a bosnia no vuelvas a
venir a croacia ahora el invierno está
llegando cómo puedo quedarme aquí tengo
que ir a italia
mi familia me esperan italia is waiting
for me y tal y al menos dos mil 500
migrantes mal viven en los bosques y
campos improvisados cercanos a la
frontera croata sin ningún tipo de apoyo
gubernamental killing so we are coming
to save vinimos aquí para estar seguros
pero nos patean nos golpean sería mejor
que nos matarán así que la próxima vez
que lleguemos allí deberían matarnos ya
hemos tenido suficiente realmente hemos
tenido suficiente
hemos intentado cruzar 14 veces en un
año
jr
pero qué pasa en voz de ejerce gomina
alerta a la organización internacional
para las migraciones que califica la
situación como el inicio de una crisis
humanitaria
es lo que falta ahora mismo es la
voluntad política o el coraje político
para establecer un nuevo centro y de
hecho esto es lo más frustrante de la
respuesta humanitaria en bosnia y
posibilitar un bus de la óyeme y
amnistía internacional piden soluciones
urgentes para los cientos que permanecen
sin refugio ni ayuda básica preocupa la
llegada del invierno y un posible
contagio de kobe 19 entre los migrantes
las autoridades estiman que en
bosnia-herzegovina hay unos 10.000
migrantes y solicitantes de asilo
procedentes en su mayoría de afganistán
pakistán y bangladesh hasta aquí
migrantes de france24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 siga conectados
con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]